yeah no i think uh
you know congrats man um i know this is
going to come out after the other remix
is out so you got yg on the
remix 2.0 remix 2.0 my dog yg
what was that an organic thing yeah how
did that
i've been i'm just cool with everybody
man i'll just be around you'll be
playing basketball with everybody that's
for damn sure
yeah i do that's how me and blueface got
cool
okay i was hooping i pulled up to la
fitness
he told me pull up and hoot polo g was
there too so us three we was hooping
and then he was like you're trying to go
with me to san diego
to perform at these schools and then i
went with him in san diego and he was
going to school he was lit
it's in san diego yeah you i always see
you hooping uh with the who's who
uh of hip-hop uh who's the best
basketball player
in in that you've played with
artist-wise
um it's a good question right
it's a great question i mean you know
you played with all these cats who
really who's really with with i mean i
don't lose often that's the thing
i'm not talking about yourself not lost
at all so yeah i mean okay
it's putting yourself aside okay putting
me aside
yeah cause i'm the best you think you're
the best yeah i'm the best
better than cuevo yeah so you put me to
the side i never played cuevo though
cueva was good you play chris brown i
play
with chris brown and and you think
you're better than chris brown
chris brown's pretty good i think i
think chris brown is good at everything
he's pretty good he's pretty good like
he'd be good at like whatever
i just feel like when i'm on the court
it's not i don't
see look i'm not a dribbler i'm not no
you just spectacular passer you're just
shooting but i'm strong as hell
i'ma hit that shot if you let me make
that [ __ ] i'ma keep making that [ __ ]
and if you let me back you down you're
like jj reddick
i'm like you're staying in the corner a
lot of people just shot shoot the three
you're like hip hop jj reddy no a lot of
people compare me to steph curry
with a little bit of dwyane wade jesus
yeah that's kind of random
steph curry shout out dwyane wade um
yeah you never gave me your answer
though who was the best in your opinion
um outside of yourself obviously i
played
uh black boy jb he was pretty cool
really he was all right
he was mid-level but i'd give it to him
he beat me
kind kinda sorta kinda i might have
recorded it
is it oh it was recorded yeah i uploaded
it oh you i haven't seen it
so blackboard jb got he beat you he just
he just was just like
he had a lot of energy and i didn't
expect him to and plus
my brother bet 500 dollars on me so they
put a lot of pressure on me so i'm like
damn i got it
so you guys went under 500 yeah i got to
win my brother money and [ __ ]
but he was he he was going to get that
fire he didn't want to pay the 500 but
it wasn't my 500
so i didn't care as much as he cared you
know what i'm saying i got you so he
went way
harder than i did but we rematched it up
with